Harvey Weinstein faces allegations of
sex trafficking in a new lawsuit actress
KD & Noble says the disgraced movie
mogul sexually assaulted her in 2014
during the Camden film festival in
France in an interview first on CBS this
morning she says Weinstein lured her to
his hotel room with the promise of a
movie room Nobles lawsuit claims
Weinstein recruits solicits and entices
young female actresses Trika Duncan is
here drinkin good morning good morning
Katie and Noble told us that she met
Harvey Weinstein on one other occasion
in London three months before the
alleged assault she says that's when
Weinstein told her that he had a film
role in mind for her and when he said it
will be good for you she believed him I
still can hear his the rattle from his
violently him undoing his wallet what
was he had grip of me British actress
Kate Ian noble says she was forced into
a hotel bathroom and sexually assaulted
by Harvey Weinstein in May of 2014
noble says Weinstein approached her at
the Majestic Hotel during the film
festival and can France inviting her
upstairs to his room to watch her
audition real it seemed like it went on
forever and he basically took just
completely just touched me
inappropriately angle me to put it might
force my hand in places Noble is suing
Harvey Weinstein his brother Bob and The
Weinstein Company for damages
according to the complaint as Noble
fought back Weinstein told her
everything will be taken care of for you
if you relax Jeff Herman is Nobles
attorney Harvey wasn't acting alone
Harvey wasn't allowed and enabled to do
what he did to Katie and other women
without help the federal lawsuit claims
Weinstein engaged in sex trafficking by
traveling from the u.s. to London and
France where the alleged assault took
place CBS News legal analysts repeat
Kleman by using this sex trafficking law
you could extend the statute of
limitations for a civil suit to ten
years so it's a very creative use
of the sex trafficking law Harvey was a
legend he was someone that I thought was
going to meet my dream of reality Nobel
says this experience has broken her I'm
not the same person you know I've had to
have counseling just so much what I've
had to keep it to myself I've kept it to
myself
Herman believes his client is entitled
to millions authorities in Los Angeles
and New York have been communicating
about other allegations Harvey Weinstein
has already unequivocally denied any
wrongdoing we reached out to Harvey and
Bob Weinstein and The Weinstein Company
for comment on this suit but have not
heard back again this is a situation - I
asked her did you tell the police did
you tell someone she said she did tell a
friend and then she said she also told
one of Harvey Weinstein's assistants
though I'm very disturbing tarika thank
you very much